russian opposition leader alexi navalny
remains hospitalized here in berlin in a
medically induced coma
he's recovering from what german doctors
say was most likely
poisoning but the kremlin has rejected
this diagnosis
saying german doctors were too hasty
with their conclusions
now this today from a spokesman kremlin
spokesman
we are categorically against someone
labeling this current situation of
poisoning which
is something that is not confirmed yet
this is a russian citizen who is in a
coma and we would like to find
out the reason for this coma
russia is under increasing pressure to
investigate navalny's illness
tests have confirmed have all the
hallmarks of a
nerve agent attack germany is demanding
a full and transparent investigation a
call that's backed by the european union
the united states and the uk
can conserve the reaction of the german
government
is based on the clinical findings of the
treating physicians
and of course these findings are made
without any political influence
the german government expects the
russian authorities to provide
transparent and speedy clarification
and has full confidence in the work of
the medical team treating mr navalny
at charite hospital
all right for more on this i'm joined
now by andreas nick he's a member of the
german parliament's foreign affairs
committee he's also a member of
german chancellor angela merkel's
conservative cdu party
mr nick is in montebaur in western
germany tonight
mr nick it's good to see you again
germany
germany was first to call on russia to
investigate
the european union the u.s and the uk
are now doing the same that's a lot of
pressure in unison is it enough to make
the kremlin do something
i think that remains to be seen the jury
is out uh
we have been very forthcoming in
offering
uh medical treatment to mr navalny first
of all we
hope for his complete and full recovery
and it is a matter of urgency a matter
of great concern
uh it is not a one-off it's
another one in a series of dubious
killings and assassination attempts of
russian opposition
politicians over the last couple of
years
and i think it is there to send a clear
message that being a
leading opposition politician in russia
is a very dangerous role
well what leverage does germany have
with
putin's russia at this point do you have
sent russian diplomats home in protest
before
but even that seemed symbolic and
nothing more do you do you have real
leverage
i think may i remind you that the
european court of
human rights was issuing an interim
measure end of last week which was
instrumental also in getting mr navalny
out of
russia and into the charity hospital i
think what we can do at the moment is
clearly call upon a full
and transparent investigation this has
to be conducted prompt
independent and effective we are
clearly looking at that where as a
matter of urgency it is uh
as i think as also our foreign ministry
has made clear
this will not really remain unanswered
and we keep all our options and
instruments open as we speak you know mr
nick
before alexi navalny was medevaced out
of siberia and brought here to berlin
the story was mainly about a german
ngo trying to help a russian political
dissident
as soon as mr navalny landed here though
that story
quickly became political is that what
you and your fellow lawmakers in
parliament did you want
it to be that way
i think our government has taken i think
the necessary
measures that someone whose family is
asking for
medical treatment in our country in
berlin and the charity
gets access to that and clearly it is
over symbolic also for symbolic but very
also very practical nature
that uh the personal security of
mr silvani in the charity is secured by
federal agents
of the federal police department
i think we have no interest to
politicize this in the first place i
think this is about human rights this is
about the rule of law
i think it would be a mistake if we were
giving
additional uh
feeding the the the legend that this is
part of a geopolitical
struggle or anything else i think this
is about very fundamental uh
rule of law issues that russia also as a
member state of the council of europe
has to comply with
were you surprised mr nick to see how
quickly the united states also came on
board and demanded
that russia investigate
well i think we have more question marks
about uh
at least the the role of some
representatives of the united states
when it comes to
specific issues regarding russia i think
this may also be not a coincidence that
this is happening
now in the run-up to the us election and
in
in the context of the belarus protests
uh we will we will see i think again
uh all of us i think would be well
advised
not to frame this or to support framing
this into part of a geopolitical
struggle
but it's a very fundamental issue about
the rule of law and
fundamental human rights in the russian
federation
i know i mean i just want to appreciate
this while we have time
germany and the u.s are united in this
case
but when it comes to the nord stream 2
pipeline for example you're not the
trump administration accuses germany of
making itself dependent on russia
for energy do you sometimes feel mr nick
that
germany is caught between a a russian
rock
and an american hard place
i think we are we don't uh think that uh
unilateral sanctions as
applied and threatened by the us
government increasingly are
at all helpful i think they are
counterproductive uh
we strongly advise from refraining from
this kind of action against an
ally like germany and respecting
the political economic sovereignty also
of an allied nation
i think is is one of the core elements
of our alliance
nonetheless i think we have uh issues
with regard
to the russian federation where i think
we are hopefully in broad agreement that
uh
that we we ask uh strongly asked russia
to
come back to the peace and security
order
that has been that has been agreed in
the carter of paris in 1990
which i think for us is still the key
point of reference of living together in
europe
andreas nick member of the german
parliament's foreign affairs committee
as always mr nick we appreciate your
time and
your insights tonight thank you thank
you
well the cinema for peace foundation has
played a key role in bringing
russian opposition activists here to
berlin for treatment at the
charity hospital it did so with a [ __ ]
riot activist
in 2018 and it medevaced alexis navalny
from siberia
to berlin just last weekend now the
group's chair
jaka biezel told dw's chief political
editor mikela coffner
how the arrangements were made
jakar bizil you are the head of cinema
for peace but most of all at the moment
you are the man who brought
alexay navalny to germany how safe do
you feel right now well
there have been a few threats but i've
experienced this before so i don't
really feel unsafe
i think that what happens when you deal
with opposition leaders from countries
which are not a full democracy
who did you call first because it's not
easy to just get a permit to enter
russia just like that
well first i called the charity and
professor aina had been professor
eckhart
to find out if they would be willing to
help again like they did two years ago
and was kind of a bit funny funny
because the office said like oh you're
calling finally we've been expecting the
car ready since this morning since we've
seen the news
so they they thought that it could be a
similar case possibly
how much assistance did you get from
that first moment from the german
government
um actually we informed them about
things that we were doing
but the very first moment was more the
logistical work obviously we were aware
of the fact that angela merkel and
macron had been
giving some statements and we're
offering medical help in their countries
so we felt like that there should not be
any obstacles from that side
how has the last week changed your view
of the political reality
in europe well i mean what we are proud
of in the west is that we have so-called
western values and democracies
and i think after what has been
happening with donald trump
what has been happening with corona it
felt like that there's an erosion
of democratic values
and also of european unity i think if
the west wants to stay the west
it needs to take a clear stand for human
rights and democracy
and it also needs to prove that in
relationship to the rest of the world
what's your biggest hope and your
biggest concern right now
well my hope would be that the patient
will come back to normal fully
i saw last night by chance's wife julia
again
she seemed kind of like
[Music]
okay i have the feeling that
navalny could be doing a little bit
better now by now
so my hope would be that actually the
whole thing will be resolved in a sense
that
he will be able to do his work again and
then maybe the whole case can also
remind
our countries to work on russia
to to protect as journalists and
opposition politicians
and not to be a country where people
like annapolis kaya boris nemtsov
or nova navalny have to fear for their
life
jaka bazil thank you very much for
talking to us
thank you